i want to talk to you about a whole
bunch of stuff you got me two of my
brothers and bill barrheight from uh
abra here first i want to start with the
big news of the bitcoin etf what's your
read on the launch of the bitcoin etf
and the impact on the market
i like it
as an indicator that the regulator is
warming up to finally um
you know providing guidance and
regulation
for the real thing i don't like it as a
product if i'm going to be exposed to
the price of bitcoin why don't i just
buy bitcoin and so the futures market is
very efficient but sometimes when prices
are very volatile not so much and so
look it's great that it's happened it's
clearly reflected in the overall price
of bitcoin with the optimism globally
that the us regulator is finally going
to get behind cryptocurrencies not just
bitcoin and it's a first baby step but
frankly you can buy an etf with the real
thing underlying up in canada right now
and other countries are doing that even
with ethereum now in canada so you know
hopefully within 24 months which is sort
of my time view we're going to have the
real thing
bitcoin inside an etf wrapper that
allows people with equity portfolios to
buy it and get price exposure to the
price of bitcoin into cryptocurrencies
it's not a bad thing you can't say it's
bad but it's not the way i i don't want
to invest in it that way and why pay the
fees why don't you just buy bitcoin and
hold it in a decentralized wallet and i
think that's the most efficient way to
do it what are the institutions saying
to you about the etf does this kind of
like an open the kimono now they think
that they can start to allocate to the
uh asset because there's an etf approved
no
no this doesn't it still hasn't been the
majority of institutions and the wire
houses that run the very large brokerage
community
are not there yet this has not been
approved by compliance just the fact
that it's a futures contract in itself
just futures contracts are for
accredited investors only anyways so
it's a small subset to start off with
and they can buy it on their own in an
online account but the major houses have
not approved this yet
okay when we think about monetary policy
the fed actions and kind of inflation
talk to me about your view right now
we've now had multiple months of over
five percent cpi core inflation's at
four percent uh and we continue to get
this idea of a lot of people saying it's
all transitory how do you think about
inflation and then also what the fed's
actions should be moving forward
so
i spend a lot of time on this model
because it's reflected in my operating
costs in the 34 private companies that i
own
everything from gym equipment
manufacturers to commercial kitchens
insecticide companies this is how broad
the portfolio is what is happening right
now is supply chain issues and it's
reflected in what i call transitory
inflation let me give you an example i
can't get parts off a ship that's moored
outside of los angeles for six days i
just found that out before i came on the
air because it's stuck in a jam trying
to get into the port we're not operating
the la port 24 7 which is insane in
itself but because i can't get those
parts i'm scrambling to buy parts so i
can finish off manufacturing equipment
and i'm paying up as much as 30 percent
to find those parts in the secondary
market that is reflected as an
inflationary increase in my cost of
goods it's happening all through the s p
500 so the fact that we can't get our
logistics figured out is the reason we
have inflation right now in every aspect
of business the same thing in trying to
move you know operations out of staffing
facilities we have in china to vietnam
just to move the the molds i can't even
get a container it's four times more
expensive than it was just 18 months ago
to get a container to move the equipment
so inflation is a result of broken down
supply side logistics when we think
about those supply chain disruptions how
much of it is initiated by the fact that
people were handed money they started to
spend that money in the economy they
drove up demand and the supply chains
weren't ready for the demand and that
ultimately broke the supply chains which
then leads to the increased prices or is
it just no the supply chains coming out
of kovid they kind of got shut off then
turned back on and it's the turning back
on that's actually breaking them
well you're right the consumer never
turned off even in the height of kobe
you know february march april last year
when it was just you know a huge
pandemic they still had those stimulus
checks and they were still ordering
everything online and so the the amount
of traffic that started direct to
consumer really put pressure on
logistics for transportation both in
inbound goods in the u.s and then
distributing those goods within major
metropolitan areas and it never stopped
it just kept growing and growing and
growing i'll give you an example nike
you know a behemoth global company
in five months got to 50 direct to
consumer they thought it was going to
take them six years and that's the good
news the bad news is the amount of
logistics you need to be able to ship
sneakers all over the world whether it's
phnom penh cambodia or new york city put
tremendous pressure on the systems in
place and so we have got this remarkable
situation now with huge consumer demand
six seven eight nine percent gdp growth
and we don't have the infrastructure to
support it i'll give you another case or
use case where it's a big problem that
i'm dealing with now chip shortages we
only make 25 of the semiconductors in
the global demand here in the united
states the other 75 in asia we can't get
the chips i don't care if it's a truck
you're trying to buy from ford or
something from me and consumer
electronics i cannot get the supply how
did that happen to us how is that
possible it's not about just in time
inventory we need just in case inventory
in case the man is up stripping what we
thought it was going to be which is
exactly what's happening right now so
one of the uh repercussions of this is
as we get higher levels of inflation
obviously all the people who are holding
fixed income whether it's pimco or some
of the other really large uh fixed
income asset managers but also the
pension funds the endowments the
foundations the really large asset
allocators that uh depend on this stuff
uh as part of a large portion of their
portfolio they now all seem to really be
struggling and the reason why they're
struggling is just because on a real
return basis they're now returning
negative on that fixed income and so
what are you seeing there as like a
repercussion of the higher inflation and
how people are thinking about their
it's a huge problem it is a massive
problem because the traditional
allocation to an institutional portfolio
was 60 equity 40 fixed income generally
that fixed income in a foreign form of a
ladder of government bonds average
duration maybe nine years and corporate
credits will be in about five to seven
year duration and they would always pay
you two to three hundred basis points
over inflation that's not the case today
there's lots of corporate paper being
issued right now under three percent for
five to seven year duration when
inflation is 2.1 percent the real return
is is is almost zero in terms of buying
power and so that's incredibly risky and
it's one of the reasons you've seen such
an incredible demand or interest in
stable coins that can be staked out at
five six seven percent for 30 60 90 days
and that's got the regulator really um i
wouldn't say upset but concerned stable
coins have become the focus of the
regulator right now because people are
treating like money markets and in some
cases they may not be that what do you
think happens there with those stable
coins
so you're well aware of the tether
situation you know that circle has uh
started with just two years ago
practically nothing in west dc and that
was over 30 billion dollars
that's a lot of money and most of that
is in the hands of high net worth
individuals family offices hedge funds
it is not yet approved institutionally
for reasons we already know the
regulator is scrutinizing it
i think the genie's out of the bottle or
the ship has sailed or whatever analogy
you want to use we're we're not
it's it's not going to be made illegal
it's going to be regulated now how much
balance sheet assets you need to support
your stable coin is going to be the
debate and frankly i think the smart
move is being done by the ceo jeremy at
circle by simply saying to the regulator
turn me into a bank regulate me like a
bank because that's what i am i'm being
treated like a bank by my investors and
once that happens and if it does i think
that's a really good first step because
you know i think it's easier to regulate
stable coins backed by usd
or whatever you know short term jurase
duration government credit
and and get that through the meat
grinder of the regulator than it is
bitcoin which is so controversial for
all the reasons you've been talking
about for years so if i saw that happen
first
that would be great it would be a good
step forward and then then the debate
about decentralized finance and
financing and payment systems that'll
come into focus next there's just so
much going on it's it's incredible right
now so circle is uh let's just refer to
them as kind of a private market
participant that's doing this uh other
private market participants would be the
large banks we know jp morgan tried to
launch jpm coin there's a couple of
others that have tried stuff uh how do
you think about the private market doing
this versus let's say the united states
with like a central bank digital
currency or or some sort of state-backed
effort
i don't think they're entrepreneurial
enough to pull it off i really don't um
what what what happened in circle
if you meet that management team is i
have uh
these are very very um savvy
entrepreneurs that are working within
the crypto community with their version
of what a stable coin is they moved very
very quickly they had you know virtually
nothing under management just 24 months
ago and now we're past
23 24 25 billion and it's going up every
week
you don't see that in the traditional
banking system because
they're trying to protect their own
systems that they have already in place
if they don't want to cannibalize
themselves and frankly if they were
successful in launching a stablecoin
they would have to do it under their own
compliance systems which are and the and
those compliance officers in a giant
wire house know that the regulator is
scrutinizing
all of the players in crypto in stable
points and they're going to wait till
there's a judgment they're not going to
go and start fighting with the regulator
and a jp morgan that's not going to
happen
and so this is a really interesting
story of the hair and the turtle you
know
starting very slowly
sometimes you can win but maybe not in
crypto once you get scale once you
become a standard once everybody's using
your platform and writing and you know
staking and loaning and doing it
i'm doing that right now at circle i'm
putting out contracts of 30 60 90 days
on usdc i go to fiat usdc i get paid
back in usdc and i can convert back to
feed in any currency but to get that
through my own auditor
took me six months
let alone that's getting them to agree
to sign the statement so i can file with
the regulator i mean this is going to
take a while how much are you earning
when you do some of this stuff like what
are their general rates and what i'm
trying to compare it to is like the
fixed income guys who are earning you
know five six uh seven percent on their
like highest risk stuff lower risk stuff
was kind of you know one two percent
what what is it in the stable coin world
right now
well
each platform is different right now you
see some very attractive rates on ftx if
you if you're able to set up an account
and you have compliance will let you do
that including their own compliance
which is very heavy scrutiny um they
make sure it comes on that platform uh
whatever geography they're in
remain compliant with their own law you
know code in whether switzerland france
or canada or whatever uh you can do more
than seven percent on ftx right now and
staking uh circle contracts right now
yesterday i did some at 6.2
for 90 days that's very attractive on
usdc so you're you're you're beating
inflation you do have regulatory risk i
mean if tomorrow morning i wake up
and uh usdc is no longer
allowed by the regulator that ain't good
news and so that's why there's some
hesitancy but you know we have as a
weighting probably less than
one percent in the particular mandate in
usdc right now but i would take it up
way bigger if the regulator would let me
and and i would probably have i'd put
our cash in there you know it could be
20
and because i don't want to make 22
basis points that's what my cash test is
giving me right now 22 basis wise when
inflation is 2.1
yeah it's crazy uh you now are mr
wonderful you're world famous abc shark
tank i see you smile when i say it if
there's humans on mars they know who you
are uh so this isn't just like a uh
western hemisphere conversation right
it's not just about the united states
and canada i know that you've got a
number of different friends colleagues
and peers all throughout the middle east
europe what are they all saying about
this are they jumping in the game are
they still a little bit uh hesitant
what's the international money doing
it's very very interesting the topic
that's going to be in riyadh next week
is about crypto and there's a tremendous
amount of excitement about it but they
have not pulled the trigger yet they're
trying to get themselves set up for the
moment when the regulator allows it both
in their own geography and in the u.s
you got to remember that those those
funds those those sovereign funds
whether it be in saudi arabia or united
arab emirates a huge amount of that
capital is invested in the s p 500 and
derivatives thereof
huge amounts huge huge amounts so they
cannot be offside with the us regulator
they just can't and so
and i look at this as a huge opportunity
i speak to those guys almost every day
they would immediately go to one to
three percent on bitcoin alone just
bitcoin
let alone ethereum or any level one
level twos
on the chain they haven't even thought
about that they're just thinking about
bitcoin and and owning that as an asset
the amount of capital that will come
into this market
when the regulator approves bitcoin as
an asset or currency or a security
whatever they're going to
you know regulate it as is going to be
unbelievable which is why i own it i
mean
my premise you know stomaching the
volatility which we all do every
12-month cycle
is the upside is behemoth is huge and so
you know whether it be for me it's an
asset it's a long-term hold the coin i
own the coin is the point i own i don't
trade it i lend it i stake it
and you know i get some income from that
but i'm never going to give up the coin
and you know i heard you guys talking
about the the esg issue i'm sorry that
hasn't gone away but there have been
some new initiatives in raising capital
solve for it so before we get to the esg
stuff with this international money
right you talk about them wanting to go
one to three percent just to bitcoin
maybe they would do some other stuff as
well are we talking about just large
family offices in the middle east and
europe are we talking about uh
foundations sovereign wealth funds like
and i'm trying to use that as a proxy
for like how serious uh the most
conservative investors in the world are
about this versus oh this is a large
family office where there's kind of one
decision maker and they're going to end
up making that decision based on how
comfortable they are on a regulation
standpoint and also a return standpoint
yeah
the real opportunity is not with the
family offices or hedge funds that
operate under the middle east
the real money is in the actual
sovereign funds
in both
saudi arabia and the united arab
emirates
it's billions and billions and billions
of dollars they have not allocated to
crypto yet
when that happens
you'll see it reflected in the price of
bitcoin there's no question about it and
they have such long-term views in those
funds
that and the funds are so large
remember
these countries don't operate the same
way as the west domestic countries do
although they're managed many of the
people managing
those middle eastern funds the sovereign
funds are actually western educated
managers and so they generally abide by
discipline and principles of uh
you know uh risk diversification so they
may have a mandate for example that no
stock can represent more than five
percent of the fund or the sector more
than 20
those are diversification mandates that
are used all around the world and they
do that there too
but when you're dealing with a
multi-billion dollar mandate
and some of these are
they're the largest proposal capital in
the world a one percent allocation
is a tremendous amount of money and so
there's a whole bunch of people and me
included heading over in november um and
everybody is talking about not just
bitcoin anymore is what would a
portfolio look like
if
you know the managers are asking this of
participants that are already building
these portfolios give me an allocation
of positions if i want to be exposed to
bitcoin itself of course but also be
involved in decentralized finance and
also own level 1 and level 2 chains what
does that look like
and i'm heading over i think probably
you and i at some point in the next few
weeks i'm going to give you
my portfolio i'm not finished yet but
it's over 21 positions right now
and i'll i'll do it on your show i'll
disclose what i own i think you're going
to be knocked out but you see what i've
got here because i've gone right down
the rabbit hole i've hired multiple
people uh to do the due diligence on
some of these really eclectic projects
but we are investing in them my last
question on let's say the sovereign
wealth funds is could you see them
getting into mining at some point
yeah great question and yes that is my
plan and here's that goes to the esg
issue okay here's the solution all right
let's say you can't get a rent your
compliance department can't get around
the issue
of esg because it's still out there and
there's still half compliance uh and and
ethics committees and these big funds
and so here's a solution let's say you
go from scratch let's say you go to west
texas and you want to build a gig
facility and build it out in 250
increments and you and you basically
guarantee the investors that you're only
going to use wind and solar and you
agree to the texas grid that you'll pay
back
some of your production
and you go to the capital markets and
say every time we're awarded a coin it
stays on the balance sheet of this
investment so you know with certainty
that your coin was mined in this
facility that you own
that's what i'm doing and that's a big
solution for me because i i get to check
the box now on esg for anybody that's
you know even saying to me where does
your coin come from i can't do that if i
buy an etf i can't do that if i just go
and buy a coin in the open market but i
can do that if i was awarded the coin in
an esg compliant facility and there's
enough point to be mined left that
you're going to see a lot of capital put
to work and not just the geography in
west texas there's other jurisdictions
in northern europe that are looking at
this proposal as well so you're
basically going into the government
office saying we are going to mine
sustainably we're going to do it give us
the permits give us access to the grids
give us all the things we need to be
able to service this facility and let us
get to work so i've got bill from abra
here what's your take on the esg stuff
well uh kevin really great to meet you
uh very impressed with how deep you've
gone on this topic uh it's not easy so
much respect there
um i guess
you know two questions right first i
understand that the esg issue hasn't
quote unquote gone away
but
one do the numbers really support the
narrative when you go deep that the
issue
should exist and do you actually think
that you could produce enough energy in
wind and solar at large scale to make a
dent
uh in the hash power war assuming that
we get back to the current
uh hash power numbers by this time next
year actually i'm assuming we would be
ahead of the the
pre-china crackdown numbers by this time
next year and would wind in solar
actually make enough of a dent to even
warrant the investment
it's a great question you can't do it
with solar alone it's a combination of
wind and solar which makes it expensive
but it's definitely it's g compliant and
let me tell you
i agree with you around the debate i
mean if you want to own bitcoin own
bitcoin but it's not that simple if you
have a compliance department and you
have the larry fink letter hanging over
everybody knows about the larry think
letter in fact everybody also knows that
blackrock has hired a chief esg
officer and so if you are being serviced
by and every sovereign fund in the world
works with blackrock pretty well
you really can't go against that mandate
it's not going to work for you you've
got to solve it and so the question is
you got to check the box on esg or you
can't play in the coin space if you're
tied into those metrics so it's not like
they don't want to
it's they can't it's the same issue
about you know buying certain goods and
services from banned countries
that's what the ethics committee stopped
you there too i i really i really work
in this in this in this institutional
world and
it's not like you can call up the chief
compliance officer and have a dialogue
regarding the merits of mining bitcoin
with existing energy sources
they just don't give a [ __ ] they're not
going to take the call
they're just saying no so when they see
how much money is being made in the
space don't you think they're just going
to change the narrative to fit what they
need it to be to make the investment
which is what i mean come on they do
that anyway
i mean and also they're not eliminating
all the companies from the fortune 500
that probably wouldn't pass muster on
the same usage around esg
uh if they weren't already in the
portfolio today
well that's not true actually if you
look at the allocations even calpers
alone said this after the faint letter
they're going to downsize their energy
holdings
but probably we're up at 20 they may be
down as low as eight now and you can see
it reflected in large energy energy
names like
uh you know schlumberger and exxon and
mobile
they're they're they're getting their
pes compressed because the incremental
buyers not there anymore
on the highway on the hydrocarbon
mandate coming out of the white house so
there's some pretty big uh forces at
play and when you talk about you know if
you'd only own bitcoin at 8 000 now it's
over 60 000 to it to a sovereign fund
that's running you know
40 50 60 billion dollars it's a rounding
error right they don't care and
and it's the same time it's the greatest
opportunity for those of us that have
invested in cryptocurrencies is to solve
this problem for them i mean
it's not going to get solved
debating it with the compliance officer
it's going to get solved when they can
simply check the box saying this
facility in norway this facility in
northern quebec this facility in
northern alberta and this facility in
west texas where the places i'm looking
at
mine sustainably as
agreed to with the government the
government has
certified this an est compliant facility
then the debate's over in fact those are
the very people that i'm going to to
raise capital from to build out these
facilities because it solves their
problem the same compliance office that
won't let the fund buy bitcoin will put
money in the ground to build a facility
to to to minecoin if it's csg compliant
go figure
yep
joe john what questions you guys got hey
kevin thanks for doing this nice to see
you again uh so i remember seeing
something that you said i think it was a
month or two ago that you were going to
double your crypto exposure in your
portfolio is this something that you're
actively looking to do is this something
that you're waiting on
regulation for or have you already done
it et cetera just a little more kind of
insight into that
no i'm on my way by the end of december
i should be at seven percent of the
operating companies portfolio and the
way i'm doing it is with ftx i i became
an investor uh uh this week in ftx it's
a private company but i was able to buy
some of it because i've become the paid
spokesperson most people know that
right beside tom brady i love that
i can't wait to play some football with
him but the bottom line is they're smart
about it
they're helping me build that portfolio
with some very eclectic products
that normally is not easy to get access
to i'm really fascinated now
by the different approaches
on decentralized ledgers and so i've got
a lot of people on my team working on it
i think the nft market is going to be
absolutely huge and i'm going to be a
participant in it and i'm thinking nfts
not just on digital art
i'm thinking nft is used to authenticate
physical assets the one i'm working on
because i'm a huge watch collector and i
know all the world's largest collectors
and the ceos of all the watch companies
is authenticating secondary market watch
training i don't know if you saw that
article last week i think it was put out
by cnbc 20 billion dollars a year of
trading in the watch asset class and the
biggest problem let's say i want to buy
protect philippe that went off the
market 17 years ago which i'm doing
right now
a piece celebrating their 75th
anniversary i have to send it to a guy
named john reardon in new york to get it
authenticated to know that it's real
the hassle in doing that the cost of
doing that moving it from the the seller
in hong kong to new york city and bond
having john look at it open up make sure
it's real close it send it back to the
seller so it's in his physical hands
then do the trade
i could avoid all that with a washington
ft that once that watch was put on the
market it was reardon would do an nft to
it approve it certify it and for the
rest of that watch is life and every
time it trades
you know it's real and if we have to pay
back a royalty to protect the lead or
wherever the maker is or the designer of
the dial that's fine you can all do that
on smart contract so should that be on
solana should that be an ethereum should
be on a derivative of ethereum i don't
know yet that's the worst that's the
research i'm working on john what
questions you got yeah what's up kevin i
see you again um can you talk more about
your stable cone holdings and like any
restrictions that you have what coins
you like versus other ones
yeah
um
i've done a lot of work on stablecoin
because um this was a need about 18
months ago we took down our commercial
real estate holdings including here in
boston where i am down from 31 of the
operating companies portfolio remember
these are income producing properties so
it's a form of our
way we made income and the cap rates got
so low here in boston new york detroit
miami we just sold it including you know
climate-controlled storage facilities
that we bought at 11 cap that were
trading at three and a half cap so it
was time to exit so we sold it down to
eight percent holdings the only
buildings we didn't sell are liquid or
have you know issues around them they
house movie theaters and things like
that
and we had all this cash so we go to the
cash desk and we say okay we have to
park this cash while we deploy it
and they offered us 23 basis points and
i'm talking about some of the biggest
cash checks in new york and i said this
is insane you're going to give me 23
bits and and i'm you know i'm facing 2.1
inflation
that's when we started digging into
stable coin because that was the first
time we started that dialogue with
circle and other entities
and then i called up our auditors and
said look we're going to deploy some of
this cash into stable coins we chose
usdc because we really like the
compliance
team over at circle if you really those
guys understand our problems regarding
compliance and the audience said i said
no way no way you are not doing that
we're not signing uh the statements i
said that's crazy like you i want to
deploy this capital you won't sign my
status no we won't it's not it's not
approved by the regulator
i mean
guys you know
we talk about crypto collectively all
day long but
it is so early in the institutional
world it is so nasty it's so
not there yet and that in itself is the
giant opportunity i mean just stable
coins alone
would be a huge market if you could
actually lend them out even anything
over four percent now i assume when they
when they regulate it the demands will
be so high it's gonna push down yields
but right now you're talking six point
two percent on a 90 day
uh you know state which is phenomenal
unless you wake up and the regulator
changed their minds on unstable coins in
uscc which is kind of scary which is why
we can't load up we can do you know
maybe 100 basis points worth of it but
we can't put 20 of a portfolio into it i
would if it was regulated so and i'm
just one guy can you imagine what would
happen if it tomorrow morning regulators
says okay here are the rules for stable
coins here's what a stable coin money
market fund looks like yeah you have to
be a bank and then circle turns into a
bank whatever is going to happen i'm
speculating when i say that but the
demand would be unbelievable
kevin i got two questions for you and
then we'll let you go first is when you
think about uh those regulators coming
in and giving the thumbs up kind of uh
saying all right everyone go
would you go to 20 or would you do more
in your portfolio in terms of full
exposure to the industry could you see
yourself going to 50 plus percent given
that you're 50 plus percent in u.s
dollar
kind of assets and cash
well
you know it's a good question paul um
and we just had that discussion uh on
monday with our ot
just here's what i think we're gonna do
we're gonna go to seven percent on
crypto itself by december but i've also
started to take some pretty big
positions in public miners right now
that are checking the box on esg
and so i guess you could argue that if
you included that in what will call the
crypto weighting if you want to call
that an asset class and the reason i'm
doing it that way is
i really can't go past 20 in any one
sector if you call
i really believe
that that crypto is the 12th sector of
the s p we don't know it yet it hasn't
been designated that but it's coming in
in the years ahead we have 11 sectors
now including real estate crypto is
going to be number 12 primarily driven
by decentralized finance it's so
disruptive so powerful so productive
it'll get there so i want to have more
exposure during that transition
um
and i guess the way to do that and and
keep my own compliance department on
board my own auditor on board is to
simply buy
the securities of those compliant miners
that are trading with the volatility of
bitcoin's pricing
and i think that will get you know i'm
going to be discussing this in in abu
dhabi in november and i'll present the
portfolio there same thing in the same
arrests there's a huge conference there
in switzerland in january about this
exact topic that you're raising this
exact topic
very high net worth individuals and
family offices in europe
are i guess it's not a secret anymore
but it's it's happening and and a lot of
the crypto players are going to be there
presenting their their way of indexing
crypto i'll show mine i'll listen to
everybody else's
um
i bet you i'm spending 40 percent of my
day now on this on this topic maybe even
50 because it's performing so well
i mean i don't have anything performing
this well so
my predictions
back in 2018 the first time you and i
ever went on television i said yeah i'm
gonna remind you you forbid me for being
over fifty percent
and why are you such a dick about that
here's my prediction is that in the next
five years more than 50 of your
portfolio will be in but not from a
sense of i know you have these 20 kind
of limitations but i think what will end
up happening is your let's say real
estate portfolio people will start
paying you in stable coins so it'll be
kind of tangential or indirectly related
to it and so you'll have exposure in
more than 50 of the portfolio to these
technologies it's just not going to be
50 plus percent of you going and buying
bitcoin or you know one of the
individual assets themselves
yeah i i think you might be right on
that i'll tell you where i think it's
going to manifest itself first in the fx
market for example i use this example
all the time i have a portfolio of over
50 uh names in europe uh large cap
stocks trading in zurich in europe and
in london so they've got british pounds
you got euros you got swiss francs every
time i put on the position i have to go
usd
i have to go through an fx desk pay bips
convert to swiss francs buy the local
market when i sell the position it goes
in reverse so i'm getting clipped lots
of basis points a lot of friction there
i think when the regulators approve a a
payment system on the chain between a
market like the swiss market in the us
market uh that solves the problem
forever
i mean you're right because when i when
i buy that security i'll buy it
on a chain
in a in a way that i don't have to go
through multiple fields and
i think that's going to happen within
five years and so you're right people
are going to be exposed to crypto and
payment systems that'll represent 40 50
60 70 of their net worth they just won't
think of it that way it's a good it's a
good analogy correct my last question
for you is uh when you guys were doing
the filming for shark tank i think you
recently did that over the last few
months what's the conversation behind
closed doors uh you mark lori barbara
robert the whole crew what what are most
people uh saying about this are they all
as bullish as you are or there's still
uh some skepticism uh among that uh
crowd and i use them as a proxy for most
of kind of uh uh the average american
that is one of their biggest sources of
kind of business content is watching
shark tank so what's the thought process
of
of your co-host
well you know we don't do crypto deals
on shark tank or marijuana i mean we
don't we can't do those for because
of regulatory reasons and we we're also
very very sensitive to the regulator for
obvious reasons for you know it's a
network uh owned by disney etc
but behind closed doors um
mark and i are very very active in
crypto you know the cubit is uh we we
share notes on nfts
um
you know
i'm i'm intrigued by that whole uh
business and i'm very active in that
i've invested in uh wonderful
you know which is decentralized finance
they're bringing their app in the next
few weeks the company just raised
another 20 million yesterday
also in jordan freed's business the
platform called immutable holdings he
owns nft.com he's setting up profiles
for most of the s p 500 brands i'm
working with him on the watch industry
for example i own a piece of that
company too
you know i look at all these
i look at this stuff probably of the
sharks two uh two out of us
are are allocated
portfolios to it the other is not so
much yet but they're very interested
they're more traditional in how they
deploy capital but
i don't know how you
how you can ignore it anymore
um given the pressures that you started
this conversation with around inflation
and you know decentralized finance the
productivity you can provide to the
economy
you just can't ignore it and i
understand the regulatory cloud i get it
but i don't think even the regulators
want to abandon the promise that crypto
has for the american economy it just has
to be the rules based and they'll get
there eventually even if it takes time
that's where we're at so the sharks that
are not yet allocating is this basically
a question around regulatory or is it
they're not yet convinced or what is
kind of the biggest um critique or the
biggest obstacle that you see
turning them from uh not being allocated
to actually getting allocated
primarily regulatory i mean you know
with
without naming any specific shark they
all have big brands they all support all
kinds of companies some of them have
their own products goods and services
around their name
and it's it's the same reason that they
don't they don't get involved in the
cannabis market it's a schedule one
regulated narcotic in multiple states
and yet it's legal and others but
they they have to be compliant and so
any they all have advisors and
you know it's like i said earlier i have
to fight my auditors i have to say no no
no no you don't get it they say we get
it and the answer is no and so
it takes a fair amount of of energy to
pursue this when all the advisors around
you are saying no and won't even support
you
i mean
that's
that's really
the truth about what what crypto is now
is it's a growing
it was a baby five years ago now it's a
teenager and it's nasty because it's not
stopping it's gonna keep going and it's
gonna be an adult soon and those teenage
years are a [ __ ] that's the problem
i know you well enough that all you need
to do is when you talk to the other
sharks say listen i believe in it so
much i got my own doe in it and when you
say that they'll obviously understand
that uh if you're uncomfortable they
should be they know they know and
everybody's interested to see what my
holdings are i get that every day you
know what i'm really worried about i
don't want to be one of these guys that
you know gets some obscure token or coin
and promotes it and you know all that
stuff i don't want to be seen that way
i'm being very careful to make these
long-term investments because i believe
in you know the best way to look at this
and i i tell people this that really
grill me on crypto and particularly when
that you keep floating that video of us
together on cnbc you know on twitter and
i get abused over and over again i'm
never going to forgive you that i'm
going to figure a way to get you back i
don't know how i'm going to figure it
out but what i tell them is
look
do you invest in google do you invest in
microsoft those are big holidays for me
they are software companies when you
invest in crypto and the blockchain and
the level one level two ideas out there
and a lot of these tokens and a lot of
these shared ledgers you're investing in
software why would you invest in
microsoft and not in the chain
why
why wouldn't you and they said well i
never thought of it that way well think
about it that way because that's what it
is you're just adding to your software
productivity portfolio now i get it it's
controversial and all the rest of it but
the innovation that's occurring
by these developers the hottest hands on
the keyboard are now in crypto the
smartest guys
are doing this work and you're getting
engineers are leaving traditional
productivity software like crazy to go
into crypto whether it's a startup or
work with a behemoth or whatever it is
because the productivity
opportunities there are greater than
anything else we have in software and so
you know i just gave you the use case
for watches it's your every asset class
it's all coming but it's all software
so the politicians that say shadowy
super coders kevin says the hottest
hands are on the keyboard i like that
that's a much better way to put it i
think
yeah well i mean look politicians have
to make press uh they're constantly
raising capital from their own campaigns
i understand the pressure they're under
nothing gets you more press
the two ways to get press these days is
beat up facebook which always works it
gets you on the hill which is ludicrous
because they're the backbone of small
business in america
and talk about crypto as being used for
crime that's going to get you a lot of
headlines that's going to help you raise
a lot of money it's never going to stop
but that's not what crypto's about
anymore decentralized finance is going
to be very disruptive very powerful very
productive it's going to eliminate a lot
of fees and it's going to make life a
lot easier for everybody like me when i
talked about trying to buy and sell
european stocks in multiple currencies
i mean why wouldn't i invest in that of
course all right where do you want us to
send people you can go follow you on
twitter where else
um come and look at my i'm doing a lot
of this stuff on youtube so you know mr
monofall on youtube good place to go i
discuss this every week practically on
linkedin also doing a lot of white
papers on there
there's a lot of interest on linkedin
which is you know primarily managers in
what's going on in crypto
um so
i i think that i think the genie is out
of the bottle now and this is going to
be forever a debate
um and you know kudos for you for
bringing it out early on and becoming a
you know
marching to that tune when everybody
thought it was crazy including me but
you know when things change i change and
things have changed i i always tell
people i said listen i've got one clip
i'ma play it forever but after that you
eventually changed your mind and uh and
the thing that i will give you a lot of
credit for which i don't think people
really uh understand is it's one thing
to change your mind right you can go
from hey i don't like this okay now i'm
okay with it but it's another thing to
say it's not just going to be half a
percent or one percent right you're
talking about going to seven percent
eventually maybe 20
like it's it's uh going from being a a
critic or a uh having critiques to now
saying no hold on a second not only do i
like this but i'm gonna press the
winners right i'm gonna go in because
that's where i'm actually spending 40 50
of my time that's where a big portion of
my portfolio goes and i think a lot of
people they they get caught up in uh not
having the uh intellectual flexibility
they already were against it and now
when they say okay fine i like it a
little bit they don't want to be seen as
going all in on it right becoming a big
proponent which you've obviously done so
i i will forever always respect you for
changing your mind which i think uh most
people they can give you [ __ ] on twitter
i'm going to keep inciting that but
other than that
you're good at my book
well look i really appreciate it great
talking to you guys take care i'm sure
we'll get together again soon all right
sounds good talk soon
bye-bye